a rolling stone gathers no moss but a
walking talking pile of them that's
another story
marble fans notice the slight change to
cord between his appearances and thor
ragnarok and Avengers endgame which
illustrates the extent to achieve meek
and Thor let themselves go during end
games five-year time jump when Bruce
Banner and rocket arrive at new Asgard
to attempt to recruit the Thunder God
for The Avengers time heist course
lovely blue queue was also marked by
patches of green yes the affable rock
dude is suffering from a bit of moss
infestation look see he is on the bucket
feel free to log into the water if you
pause the movie to examine him closely
which you can now that Avengers end game
is available digitally you can see that
he's downright lousy with the stuff
astute Reddit user amazing spider-man 1
was the first to point out the change
writing an endgame you can see that cork
has moss forming on his rocks that was
not there in Ragnarok showing how gross
the lives of the boys have become though
some eagle-eyed viewers noticed during
the movie's theatrical run it's easy to
miss this subtle visual signifier during
the scene considering it's the
introduction of the version of Thor the
directors called bro Thor Thor's extra
pounds the result of five years of
terrible eating habits even worse
drinking habits and sitting around
playing fortnight's have been the
subject of all manner of commentary
since end games release while some fans
lamented the fact that the Asgardians
wait game fueled by depression over his
failure to stop Thanos from decimating
half of all life in the universe was
played for chief jokes others were
positively moved by the filmmakers
sensitive treatment of what seemed to be
PTSD helped along by Chris Hemsworth
performance and game accomplished what
no previous Marvel film had done it
brought the God of Thunder down to earth
showing us mere mortals that even he is
not immune from depression and its
effects
there was a heck of a lot going on in
end games entire three plus our runtime
so fans could be forgiven for
overlooking a few patches of creepy
foliage but now that we've pointed it
outs you won't be able to unsee it it's
an understated way to suggest that Thor
isn't the only one who has been sitting
on his butt for five years thankfully
will almost certainly get to see more of
or and perhaps he will have cleaned
himself up a bit thor ragnarok director
Taika Waititi who voices the lovable
stack of stones has officially signed on
to helm for love and thunder which will
make Odinson the first adventure to get
a fourth solo outing the movie scheduled
to hit screens November 5th 2021 will
see the return of Natalie Portman as
Jane Foster who will follow the
characters comics art by taking up Mia
linear to become the Mighty Thor where
that iteration Emil near will come from
since Captain America returned the one
from 2013 back to its time is a question
yet to be answered we can only imagine
chords reaction to this development will
he think that the Odinson has somehow
become a woman it sounds like he had a
pretty special and intimate relationship
with this Emma and then losing that was
almost comparable to losing a loved one
at any rate sports little hygiene
problem and end game illustrates the
fact that this massive film is probably
still hiding scores of small but
significant details and it wouldn't
surprise us if more than a few of them
are still yet to be noticed by fandom at
large of course scouring the flick for
every last hidden treasure just got a
lot easier with its digital release and
a physical media is more your speed
it'll be out on blu-ray and DVD August
13th check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about the MCU or coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]